Shawn told me to go out there I'm a
little intimidated and just people in
suits I'm going to do it had to refer to
him as his driver and not his uber
driver he said to keep it brand
ambiguous I don't know what that means
making me go out there now he's been
really mean again
[Applause]
[Music]
Chandra's just called us up and asked us
to come by to be in a drift tournament
that is having this afternoon but the
thing is whoever loses first has to be
the winners uber driver for the rest of
the day which means that you have to go
anywhere
the winner wants to go mangled up right
it is good to see you still early you're
all good what's the secret best friends
handshake we've had it for years
yeah we're here with shonduras and Dan
from what's inside so we're going to do
capture the comb the rules of capture
McKown are magnificently simple you see
this beautiful magnificent cone right
here all you have to do is captured from
the other player don't like you decide
yeah I know Sean called me up about two
hours ago said you want to come over and
hang out and I said sure I've never
drift carded before but I played a lot
of mario kart I thought I'd be fine he's
an incredible driver
put my heart out there I think I put
everything out on the course
I've got no question that I've got all
the confidence in world my trainers I
was a little nervous but that first time
when I did my move where I looked like I
was going right and then I run around I
knew what happened
yeah you know um you can't plan these
things I keep driving
come on the phone a needle picking up a
worst day I should tell that since high
school back and we'd be drifting out the
back alley just filters ass all days no
rules no regulations just drifting for
the heck of it and when I look at human
eyes it brought me back to those days
this was not I do not feel like this is
the professional drift see this was just
back today's and that was in back alley
telling me
psychological battle rhythmic turneth
that's kind of been my motto I got one
of them drifter diet asses right here
and you know this is just the carts part
of me more than I'm hardest card nothing
can go wrong
and I just think he didn't come prepared
you being a little bit too much about
YouTube not enough about drifting you
know I mean dang unfortunate that
neither Carmichael or I made it into the
final round from the last day for making
this video for want to call yourself
nonetheless we're good sports that's how
we do it over here corridor digital this
is the championship round we've got Dan
from what's inside versus Shawn from
shonduras who's going to win I don't
know capture the cone change it
[Music]
Danville s inside it was a little
intimidating his YouTube channel
presense when I looked at last night
kind of get to know your pone a little
bit he's been cutting stuff open my
things that's kind of been hindered and
from training he's uploading all those
of them videos to the internet surfing
started friending I thought that I had
him
I think I'm fully getting access Elvis
interview is getting more and more sick
as we go I think that's just my column
that's coming out so like I let
everybody down had it the only reason
why I lost is because right here and one
more question it would have been it
would have been nice to see someone out
there representing us but you know when
you go up against other youtubers that's
just way too Chris comas I know that on
the next one so Allah cancels that fun
look look forward to seeing the guys
next year especially that Carmichael
have some fire to Riley
I'll be stays drippin all right okay -
yeah yeah all right so here's the deal
in this whole contest ever I really
thought these guys are nice but then
they just put me in this your car they
put me in the car and they kind of took
it over and they made me their uber
driver and then they brought me on a
different race they brought me back up
the parks duties even colder up here and
I'm really cold and I don't have any
food and I have to pee
apparently they're taking us to some
party where it's like a Putin and they
said that it's going to be really fun
but I'm Pablo
charity purposes which I heard that most
human trafficking man literally who
invited the uber driver I think I just
saw what's the guy's name the DirectX
man Jay Paul Ryan the guy who rented I
think I just saw Bryan Singer and he
looked at me funny what's the street
address where we going chuckles huh oh
yeah you should know this like you drive
uber all day they brought me to a candy
shop they bought me candy I mean overall
I'm actually so public it like we were
driving here this is like we're driver
probably hey how's it going you want to
go out for something fun local apples
the others cut these pull one of those
off and then you just pump that yeah hop
it and eat it yes like this oh thank you
men kill me yeah buddy see that's good
right I'm in a good great tip so that's
what Apple is this girl app was really
good and my wife she makes me feel like
a free star but this guy who's making me
feel like a 5 we found a secret door so
we're inside now it's warm that's good
um give me a black forget the shoe with
firedamp oh my shoes on I'm a rebel Sean
does include my shoes Oh Sean told me to
go out there I am a little intimidated
to be honest there's a lot of people in
suits that I don't know and learned a
lot I think I'm gonna start applying it
very holy
Oh
I know he's gonna do black and they
won't in the same company I mean when
people call me and I don't know what to
do with them I just start driving right
when people call me and I don't know
what to do it might just keep them
entertained yeah it's kind of the same
thing
Thanks let's go out there and have this
fun okay we brought our drivers we were
drivers to the party
you think about it but being just being
being with you guys makes it feel a
little bit better it's a baby because oh
man like go mingle meet some people like
you're showing the rejuvenation out our
Zilla did nothing too much because it's
like to them
[Music]
oh he was you were driving right how did
you know that we were in the same river
together you'll never get married ever
networking for me you said you can
network for you oh yeah keep networking
so yeah I've made a lot of contacts I
met Matt Sylar okay you seem like a
really nice guy actually it's not water
so I could have the best day ever
thank you so much for letting me sweet
drift cards if you want to see rocket
League drift go over to the life station
crew stuff video and my long maybe if
you comment enough on what's inside
videos they'll cut one of those open
happy fun run down I'm down that would
be great see there leave me a high five
stops fun don't wake you